So now we will talk about features and labels.
And I'm going to be using Katie, as an example.
See as my artistic rendering of Katie.
And Katie loves listening to songs.
And I know it's cliche but one of her favorite song, is called Let It Go.
She really sings it all day long.
>> Can't hold it back anymore.
>> [LAUGH] Okay.
All right so it's not about singing lessons it's really about machine learning.
So in machine learning we often take as input features and
we try to produce labels.
So let me explain what this is.
[MUSIC]
Okay so we take this music and we don't input the raw music into her ears.
Katie for a sec please.
Okay.
Instead we extract what's called features.
These might be things such as intensity, or the tempo of the song, or
things like genre, or perhaps the gender of the voice.
And then Katie's brain processes it into one of two categories,
there is like and don't like.
Obviously an oversimplification of Katie's brain, but
for the time being, let's assume that's what's happening